stay tuned for more of the sammy davis
junior tribute honoring the one
heavyweight i would never dare step into
the ring with
sammy you're a true undefeated champ
wait
[Applause]
i think mike can do a little better than
that mike
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna attempt to read
this this may be disastrous
okay stay tuned for more of the sammy
davis jr trivia
honoring the one heavyweight i would
never dare step into the ring with
sammy you are truly the undefeated
[Music]
[Applause]
champion
the producers of the show the producers
of the show was hoping you'd have a
little more
feeling more mike you know a little bit
more mike tyson
you know more mike tysonism like like
hello ladies and gentlemen sammy and i
were right
i know i know you love me tonight but
will you respect me in the morning
you know i have a theory you want to
hear it sure yeah i think that if dogs
could talk they would all
sound like dave chappelle i think that's
something like that
it would sound like dave chappelle steve
i think like hold on son
wait a minute baby nobody comes back
here oh i'm tired of eating squirrels
son oh
oh good night do the beetles please come
on
please
hello i'm john and i'm paul
and i'm george and i'm ringu
all right good night here's my
impression of the 9 11 call
from johnny carson 1-1 yeah i'm sorry
yeah yeah but 9-11 was a national
tragedy
yes it was why did he laugh at that
okay johnny carson died at 80 years old
would you like to hear
my impression would you like to hear my
impression
okay you be the uh 911 operator hello
operator
operator mary uh yeah what is your 9-1-1
emergency
i feel like there's a yak on my chest
you hang out with norma is it impossible
it's pretty impossible because he's
crazy yeah
in l.a i call him and he goes uh
he goes i go what happened last week i
called you to go
you called me and i go yeah
on my phone i go yeah and he goes
oh yeah yeah i got that right oh you
didn't call me back
yeah yeah and he's serious yeah he's
crazy
you're pro hillary i think hillary
is a good woman she's just misunderstood
and sometimes people when they are
around good women
they wind up uh suiciding themselves
i want you i want you to pick up money i
want you to go on joe's show again so
literally after everything you say joe
can go i don't think so mum
that was the whole episode who's like hi
how are you joe's like no no no
no good mom joe with joe when joe is
doing the podcast with louis
he's just for three hours staring at the
worst version of himself
you're like me ma'am but you don't have
any money
it's [ __ ] weird man that's [ __ ]
weird man
it's [ __ ] weird white guy's got a
signal for nice uh nice booty and it's
subtle it doesn't even involve like
verbal content you don't really have to
talk
you just you know if i'm standing next
to the bus stop because you know where a
white guy signal for a nice booty and a
woman walk by
fred uh talks with his hands and he just
talks about portland all the time
because oh i love portland i fly over
there i have my apartment i have my
records i gotta right now
you ever make the wrong turn and next
thing you know you're
in the hood
and why do they call it hood what is it
like the entire city is a giant
sweatshirt and that's the part you pull
over your head
what is the deal
but what are we talking about man what
are we talking about
practice we're talking about practice
man we talk we're talking about
practice we're talking
about practice we ain't talking about
the game
we're talking about practice man hey
listen first of all i thought that this
was
i thought it was gonna be a lot more
black people here i feel a little
uncomfortable
there's a lot of white people here
that's all i gotta say i don't know what
that michael che what you doing here
you shouldn't be here right now you know
you should be the democratic convicted
that's where you should be right now you
shouldn't be over here you shouldn't be
they thank you check phil oh my god
dildos everywhere
oh my god yeah i watch that show
hoarders and uh
what you never see on tv is apparently
matt paxton told me
yeah yeah what the h hoarders love
dildos that's pretty weird you know you
got all these newspapers
and holiday decorations are all about
the house there you know
and uh i don't know what you do where
you going that box there buddy
yeah those are my dildos hey i'm not
hoarding dildos
i can't stop [ __ ] myself with uh
manufactured penises there i'm not i
know i'm a hoarder
and i'm a terrible terrible problem uh
unable to let things go but uh that's
called a spade of spade here buddy and
not throw out mommy's dildos good to
have you on the show nice uh nice to see
you how are things going pretty good
dave i mean
i mean there's a lot of places you could
be but i mean
anytime you're in a place like this you
think i mean i mean things start to get
you want to be on a funny place and this
is one of those funny places and then
for another place and it's not his
favorite thing
why am i that play what i wanted to be
was in a funny place and boom
i mean i'm having it right now good
thank you thank you queen latifah
okay you're so happy what did you get a
a high score on freecreditreport.com
what's going on hey cardi b does that
stand for hepatitis b
you're a dirty [ __ ] i already got paid
folks i don't give a [ __ ]
hey sean mendes is here we know you're
gay
okay you keep hiding it are you
embarrassed
you smoke more bone than a texas pit
master
[Applause]
[Applause]
all he was doing was working out yeah he
was getting up i run at 5 30 in the
morning because it's dark out and always
assume that my opponent's still sleeping
and that gives me extra strength and so
confidence
reynolds that's not my name
[Music]
okay turd ferguson
yeah what do you want
you buzzed in no i didn't yes you did
yeah
it's your opinion um you what is the
most
obscure impression that you do i think
john mullaney is like
i'm john mulaney i'm on jimmy kimmel and
i'm
loving it it's amazing up here in the
land of nowhere
where all things green and white seem to
revolve around a backup quarterback
with rockstar appeal the only thing
newsworthy is the tim tebow
appears to deserve it his cordiality
and decency are beyond comprehension
and he like accentuates yeah he points
it out
and looking at say i start to feel once
you start to feel it it starts to get
in your groove yeah and uh apparently so
is the veneer of his soul
and he adds words like he's it's like
he's got a thesaurus there it's like the
beautifulity
i'm not even sure if that's a word the
dubiousness that just went through
my brain threshold hey it was nice she
was a real nice hula
egg very sweet cute
you know my cup of tea i took a home
a good
[Laughter]
[Music]
can't you do dice directing on the
megaphone hey timmy
where's your [ __ ] rod your homo
[Laughter]
you know i mean like listen like chill
like you know there's like a lot of
stuff happening
okay i know what you're trying to say
but this is what i'm trying to say
black lives matter huh
dennis murphy has this real kind of
sing-song way
but he always gets things he's like an
old kind of news reporter we always get
stories about like young kids like
murdering each other or something
so i'll be like you know katie and cara
were bffs
because they had just bought the new
future album that had just dropped
and they were smoking kush and twerking
like just trying to fit in it's like
their lols quickly turned to wtf
they got that scene where they meet for
the first time and pacino's sitting
there with deniro
he's bringing [ __ ] down to him he's like
you sir i'm a bad guy
i am the police it's my job to stop guys
like you murderers
rapers killers that's what i do
there may come a time when i pass cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i won't
like it but i'll do it keeps me hot
on my toes where i gotta be
de niro comes back you know there's a
flip side to that coin
good friend of mine jimmy once told me
never get attached to anything that you
cannot walk out on in 15 seconds flat if
you spot the heat
coming around the corner and i also like
guys like you that like guys like me
because you keep me hot
on my toes but i gotta beg
and you're right i patch they may cross
i'm gonna have to take you down
i won't like it but i will not hesitate
great saying now hold up picture the
same scene with stallone and
schwarzenegger
you ain't gonna be able to understand
[ __ ] stallone is doing but you know
[Music]
know there's a flip side to this climb i
must have to take it down
i won't like it without doing it well
even deaf people like what do you
what do think think